here's Maryann our announcer for the day
we brought her in and honored the book
and all the promotion she's been doing
Howard this is the greatest day of my
life
the fans adore you I'm representing all
the fans we are so excited you should
read all the text the people got the
book it's amazing it's Marian brought a
cake in today really the only one person
is eating the piece so far who do you
think she made it yes she made it again
G no it hasn't been scary Gary Gary's
the only one who truly what's going on
with that cake the Mary Ann make it yeah
Marian brought it in she bought it's a
beautiful big cake
Charley sitting there all morning
bronwen's touched it right and I walked
by and I go oh somebody popped it open
and there's a little corner message live
and security goes yeah Gary had us to
bring the cake in it would be nice if I
could have seen it without a chunk music
Gary said you would have been I would
have want to wait for the cake
how is my cake it's good
[Laughter]